maybe from your perspective let me ask
the this most basic question yeah how do
you think of on your own network what is
it and you're on the one yeah okay so
can I start with a idea about deep
learning what does that mean sure what
is deep learning what is deep learning
yeah so so we're trying to learn from
all this data we're trying to learn
what's important what was them What's it
telling us so you've you've got data
you've got some inputs for which you
know the right outputs the question is
can you see the pattern there can you
figure out a way for a new input which
we haven't seen to to get the to
understand what the output will be from
that new input so we've got a million
inputs with their outputs so we're
trying to create some patterns some rule
that'll take those inputs those million
training inputs which we know about to
the correct million outputs and this
idea of a neural net is part of the
structure of the of our new way to
create a create a rule we're looking for
a rule that will take these training
inputs to the known outputs and then
we're going to use that rule on new
inputs that we don't know the output and
see what comes the linear algebra is a
big part of defining a finding that rule
that's right
linear algebra is a big part not all the
part people were leaning on matrices
that's good still do linear is something
special
it's all about straight lines and flat
planes and and and data isn't quite like
that you know it's it's more complicated
so you got to introduce some
complication so you have to have some
function that's not a straight line and
it not only doubt it done linear
nonlinear nonlinear and it turned out
that the it was enough to use the func
that's one straight line and then a
different one halfway that's so
piecewise Linear's Lee he said one piece
has one slope one piece the other piece
has the second slope and so that
introduced getting that nonlinear simple
non-linearity in blue the problem open
that little piece makes it sufficiently
complicated to make things interestingly
because you're gonna use that piece over
and over a million times so you so you
it has a it has a fold in the in the
graph the graph two pieces
and but when you fold something a
million times you've got you've got a
pretty complicated function that's
pretty realistic so that's the thing
about neural networks is they have a lot
of these a lot of these so why do you
think neural networks by using a sort of
formulating an objective function very
not a plane yeah functionally holds lots
of folds of the inputs the outputs why
do you think they work to be able to
find a rule that we don't know is
optimal but it just seems you'd be
pretty good in a lot of cases what's
your intuition is it surprising to you
as it is to many people you have an
intuition of why this works at all well
I'm beginning to have a better intuition
this idea of things that are piecewise
linear flat pieces but but with folds
between them like think of a roof of a
complicated infinitely complicated house
or something that curved it almost
curved but but every piece is flat that
that's been used by engineers that ideas
been used by engineers is used by
engineer big time something called the
finite element method if you want to if
you want to design a bridge design a
building design air plane you're using
this idea of piecewise flat as a good
simple computable approximation to pay
your you have a sense that that there's
a lot of expressive power in this kind
of piecewise Linear's yeah well that's
combined yeah you use the right word if
you measure the expressivity how how
many how complicated a thing can can
this piecewise flat guys express the
answer is very complicated yeah what do
you think are the limits of such
piecewise linear or just neural networks
its passivity of nool nose well you
would have said a while ago that they're
just computational limits that you you
know you problem beyond a certain size a
supercomputer isn't going to do it but
that does keep getting more powerful so
that's that limit has been moved to
allow more and more complicated surfaces
so in terms of just mapping from inputs
to outputs looking at data yeah what do
you think of you know in a context in
your networks in general data is just
tensor vectors matrices tensors how do
you think about learning from data what
how much of our world can be expressed
in this way how useful is this process
is the I guess that's another way to
asking what are the limits of this well
that's a good question
yeah so I guess the whole idea of deep
learning is that there's something there
to learn if the data is totally random
just produced by random number
generators then the we're not going to
find a useful rule because there isn't
one so the extreme of having a rule is
like knowing Newton's law you know if
you hit a hit a ball and moves so that's
where you had laws of physics Newton and
and Einstein and other great great
people have have found those laws and
laws of the
the the the distribution of oil in a
underground thing I mean that so so
engineers petroleum engineers and
understand how how oil will sit in a in
an underground basin so there were rules
now now the the new idea of artificial
intelligence is learn the rules instead
of instead of figuring out the rules by
with help from Newton or Einstein the
computer is looking for the rules so
that's another step but if there are no
rules at all for that the computer could
find if it's totally random data well
you've got nothing you've got no science
to discover it's a automated search for
the underlying rules yeah search for the
rules yeah exactly
yeah there will be a lot of random parts
a lot I'm not knocking random because
the that's there the the there's a lot
of randomness built in but there's got
to be some basic it's almost always
cigarettes right in most there's got to
be some signal yeah if it's all noise
then there's there's you're not really
getting anywhere well this world around
us does seem to be this seem to always
have a signal some kind yeah yeah to be
discovered right that's it
you